all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to my morning coffee thoughts
rock is my thoughts on society the
treachery everything
um
with my whiteboard my little whiteboard
so today oh my gosh
today I saw a video that really just
boggled my brain
I couldn't believe it
Okay so
Destiny had a had a clip all right I'm
gonna I'm gonna show you the clip
okay watch only hard people don't want
girls with high body count because it
shows a lot about their lifestyle you no
matter how hard you go about it chances
are if you're the type of guy that's
watching red pill content and you're
obsessed with a woman's body count
you're probably an incredibly low value
person yourself so not only are you
never gonna find the type of woman you
want you don't even deserve it you
probably deserve almost nothing in life
because you probably accomplished or
achieved or done basically nothing
like people that have achieved things in
life are like dramatically Clinging On
to other like false idols and spaces
looking for guidance like by definition
right you are that's why you're watching
that content like that is the target
audience of red pill yeah we're on the
realism Mark now okay I can only extend
so much empathy before I literally burn
myself to the ground trying to keep you
okay
and I think it's an interesting uh we're
just in an interesting Paradigm in
society
where the internet has really let us
live in in la la land
where the internet really props up a lot
of
losers yeah
now destiny is a streamer right
and I want to talk about
streamers and just this really like
and he's not the only one that does this
where they personally attack the men
that have average jobs most men make
average money so by and large if they're
a large male followings
um from Red Pill creators most of them
are going to be average guys what do we
agree wouldn't we agree most people are
average so and
when we look at the top industries that
are male dominated a lot of them so one
is a truckers that's like one of the top
employers of men
um we could also look at different you
know half of men have infrastructure
jobs so that means plumbers that means
electricians even let's say a bus driver
um
you need all of these people in order
for society to run now if Destiny stops
streaming tomorrow
all of society would be fine
honestly if all of us internet
entertainers disappeared
tomorrow we would all be gone so I was
thinking I'm like how crazy it is is it
that the man who watches people for a
living he's probably gonna react to this
right he's a he's a he's a Class A
Watcher
is going around saying all you men are
low value because you don't want [__]
I mean he doesn't say it like that but
let's let's I'm gonna interpret this I
just wanna
here
how stupid this sounds okay
okay
you're telling me okay so
men don't want
girls with high body counts because it
shows a lot of lifestyles
do you see how he changes the language I
think it shows that she's taken a lot of
dick
I I think that's what it are but let's
keep
red pill content and you're obsessed
with a woman's body count okay okay
people value person yourself okay so he
says if you watch red pill content
so let me get this straight the Watcher
of I've seen him watch hours and hours
of red pill content the man that watches
things for a living
[Music]
the the grade A the type a watcher
that's all he does is watch
sorry that sounded weird it's gonna [__]
on guys
for watching red pill content okay and
then he says you're probably a low wait
wait let me go back we
AK what are you a little value person
you're a low value person well Destiny I
see you watching a lot of Red Bell
contest
like it
okay
and the crazy thing is
the guy that doesn't that
it has a lot of smoke around him right
calling them the truckers the bus
drivers the average men that watch this
type of content that runs society that
we need calling them low value it's so
crazy because these guys get such a
sense of false like idolatry because
they they said a couple things on the
internet they went super like I'll be
the first to tell you I'm a normal chick
and you know I don't think I'm better
than anyone than any any other average
chick but these guys will sell courses
and some merch
and stream and like think through these
elf like not even I don't have a problem
with confidence but it's like you think
you're better than the bus driver
because you're a watcher you're an
expert watch okay
okay just
okay so you don't deserve the type of
women that you want now I think most men
just don't want
bad [__]
and the problem is 70 of the chicks are
overweight
and 96 percent of women are not virgins
on their wedding day so if we're gonna
go that a [__] is a woman that slept
with multiple men then really
um you're saying you you average men
that build and run Society you don't
deserve that [__]
I mean like do you see that
and see this is where you see his blue
pill mindset he thinks the women are the
prize
oh no not today's women okay
or achieved or done basically nothing
okay okay again most guys are average
most men watching content are going to
be average if you've amassed a huge
following I bet you fresh and fit it's
mostly average men
that watch their content I bet you
because most people are out you're not
going to get a big following without
average people like that's the stupidest
[__] I've ever heard so he's basically
saying I I Destiny am so amazing and I
deserve all of these hot because he he
sleeps with all the all the women he
like streams with I guess this is his
reputation okay true or false I don't
I'm not a hundred percent sure
but he's built a reputation of screwing
a lot of women he's he streams with all
right this is this is what they say
so he's saying you know why Destiny I
Destiny I am an expert streamer yes and
I therefore deserve these valuable women
and you sir that drive the buses you sir
that drive the trucks you sir that build
the buildings you construction workers
you're a low value person
that deserves nothing in life
now a lot of times these red pillars and
honestly the success Hustlers get away
with this [__]
um none of you could do what you do
without the average man that runs
Society who built the microphone
who built the house you're in
who paved the roads that you drive on
and yet they have the audacity to to
[__] on the average man and say they
don't that they're not they don't
qualify for fat [__] it's like
things in life are like dramatically
Clinging On to other like false idols
and spaces looking for guidance like by
definition right you are that's why
you're watching that content like that
well
that's all you do is watch Khan
[Music]
like I don't
like I'm not even
you're like an expert Watcher that's
like half of the [__] you react to you
you're a watcher
oh this is just like the funniest thing
I've ever heard
okay
Okay so
you know what would be
seeking out male guidance from men that
are more successful than you is actually
pretty normal now I'll give you an
example you know as
my dad is the most successful most
awesome man on the whole planet
and while my dad is not on YouTube he
doesn't like social media he said he
always says life should be lived in the
real world and not media like he doesn't
like it
um he would be the first to say
to
find people that are more successful
from then you and learn from them
and I think if you ask most successful
men
um outside of this is an internet bubble
right I'm in London there's a bunch of
Finance people like this is a bubble
it's not real well it's real but it's a
weird if you say do you guys want to
marry
horse
they'll all tell you no no I do not no
no no no
Jesus people don't want
I just couldn't believe an expert
Watcher I'm sorry guys maybe I'm being
too mean but I'm like okay this man who
watches red pill content for a living
I mean that's what
what after like getting banned on Twitch
was just watching red pill content and
arguing actually I want to show you guys
one more I was going to wait till my
show next week I might do it on my show
too
um
okay I still think it maintained that
surrogacy is evil but you cannot plan
for endocrine um cancer that you
survived you're telling me I'm [__] out
of luck about reproducing
look can you go back in time and hook up
Genevieve like we in the west just don't
have an appreciation for the sanctity of
life so we keep just trying to find ways
to commodify and play God you're begging
the question or somebody says like
because you keep saying things that
don't mean anything like oh like playing
God when we give type 1 diabetics
insulin no no no no it means something
to you either because if you go and have
birth and you get an epidural is that
plain God somebody that's getting
insulin is that playing God or we've got
somebody a panel that's had oncology
treatments inside chemotherapy radiation
is that pain they got all
the different ways right your face
doesn't work like that right the line
yeah you're like your face you've got
makeup on your face my hair is not
natural
ladies that okay let me get this
straight I just I just want you to hear
the stuff that comes out of this guy's
mouth you and the thing is he just talks
over everybody and when you're a polite
person it's just like you're like okay
um but he says
I have blue hair
that is the same as surrogacy
putting a baby in someone else is the
same as dyeing your hair
putting on makeup is the same thing as
dyeing your hair if we're gonna go down
the medical route
I think if anything the fact that we
have all these issues from you know
they're they're they're saying like
stuff is coming out now saying that the
the stuff this medicine that was
supposed to help us is actually hurting
us
um
people I've seen recordings of people
from like a hundred years ago and they
talk a lot more clear they just have a
lot of it just seems like when people do
start to play God everyone kind of just
starts dying you know
um but you know I just wanted to my
biggest point is I think we need to
appreciate the average men in society
and I'm really sick of
hearing streamers call average earners
losers when none of these streamers
um none of these guys that got rich on
social media would be anywhere without
the average men and I think there needs
to be some group appreciation for the
average men that run our society and I
think that thinking that because you got
early and quick success at a young age
because you're an expert uh streamer a
YouTuber which our industry could go
away tomorrow
honestly the world would be fine but if
the busers the truckers the plumbers the
electricians all of the average men that
a lot of you [__] on for not being rich
um went away tomorrow the world will be
a very different and very scary place so
um let me know what you guys think in
the comments like the video maybe I'm
crazy maybe the expert Watcher should
really criticize them for watching
content anyways guys like the video I'll
talk to you next time